a Zelda game without dungeons is like
Christmas without presents like you've
still got Old Saint Nick and you've got
a tree and music and food but where's
the mystery of delving into a new
dungeon full of unknown Secrets which is
actually a very smart comparison to
opening presents which I should be proud
of for coming up with and especially
after these stalking filler shika
shrines that breath of the wild was
filled with we're all hungry for the
series to return to traditional Zelda
Dungeons and in this episode this
Christmas holiday season Spirit-filled
dungeon lore episode I've asked the
Snowman himself Conrad from Commonwealth
realm to help out with explaining all of
the lore behind the dungeons of Majora's
Mask how's the weather over there sir
it's very Christmassy then again I'm in
the winter and Mountain Wonderland that
is Norway hmm I guess that's why Bandit
insisted that I do Majora's temples of
ice and rock over on my channel snowhead
and Stone Tower well without further Ado
let's wrap up the last dungeon lore
video of 2022 with a bang and keep in
mind that this video will not delve into
the discourse of what whether or not
termina is a real place according to the
theory of blah blah blah and of course
spoiler alert obviously the first
dungeon we're going to cover in this
half of our collaboration is also the
first in the game The pyramid-like
woodfall Temple located deep in the
South and swamp now one thing that's
worth going over briefly before starting
this list is the fact that the world of
termina is a deeply religious one those
who have played the game to its
completion will no doubt be familiar
with that fact as per the lore of the
game there are four deities of the land
called the four giants who each govern
one quadrant of German and the
inhabitants of said quadrants each
worship their respective Giants this
combined with the fact that the Giants
themselves occurs into the dark masks
that make up the bosses of the game
which are each located within the
temples means that these temples were
more than likely built by the different
inhabitants of termina as places of
worship for their Giants well at least
the ones in this video for the others
like the Stone Tower Temple you'll have
to hop over to my channel for that one
that being said there's still certain
specific species of lore that are more
than worth going over in regards to the
temples themselves even if we already
know why they were built for instance
the woodfall temple was probably created
by the Deku in order to worship their
giant while it's submerged positioning
at the top of a mountain that constantly
spews water over its edges is quite
Telly it could be that the Deku
ancestors that built the woodful temple
chose this location as a way to provide
a blessing upon the waters of the
Southern swamp or they were trying to
reach higher in order to better commune
with the giant or both but that's
neither here not there something that's
worth noting is the fact that some fans
believe that the temple itself was
indeed built as a side of worship but
not for the giant of the Southern swamp
because there are technically two places
of worship for the Deku in Majora's Mask
the other being the Deku Shrine which is
quite the telling name some fans believe
that this means the two sides of worship
are dedicated to two different deities
with the Deku Shrine being dedicated to
the southern Giant and the woodfall
temple being dedicated to Odawa the
giant masked jungle Warrior who's
responsible for poisoning the Waters of
the Southern swamp with his stank or at
least his mask is the Majora's Mask
manga even outrights states that Odawa
is the quote god of the Southern swamp
who stole the Deku princess due to the
Deku King neglecting his tributes to
Odawa the thing is none of the Zelda
manga are considered Canon and while
they constantly bring up very
interesting ideas that would
conveniently tie up some loose ended
lore such as the notion that Majora
itself once was a beast dragon monster
thing that fed upon the desires of
humans and danced to Bongo music for
three days straight leading to its
exhaustion and death after which it was
carved into the Majora's Mask it's still
not actual Zelda lore so disregarding
the entire odalwa God statement from the
manga we instead have a direct statement
from capora Gabor that before the events
of the game the swamp had already lost
its Guardian deity and since so dalwa
was still going strong and dancing away
inside the woodfall temple this means
that the deity of the Southern swamp is
in fact the southern Giant and therefore
the woodfall temple and Deku Shrine were
more than likely both Built To Worship
the giant not Odawa but anyway moving on
next up we have the Great Bay Temple
located in you know the Great Bay this
Temple is hidden from the main playable
area in that link must ride a giant sea
turtle in order to approach and enter
its interior but again the temple itself
was most likely built by the Zora people
in order to worship the giant of the
Great Bay there are some bosses located
within its Chambers such as the wart and
another gecko the Bandit has already
gone over the Lord of those bosses in
his Majoris mask bosslord video to be
honest there isn't much left to the
imagination for the Great Bay Temple it
is a c-bound SORA built fish-shaped
worship house that corrupted the waters
surrounding it for the powers of Majora
and that's about it wow that was fast
but we wouldn't have made this video if
there wasn't anything to talk about and
the biggest topic of them all has been
hanging above our heads this whole time
that's right it's time to discuss the
infamous nightmare inducing Moon that
took the phrase the man on the moon to a
whole new level so let's begin with what
we know about the moon and game and by
that I mean let's discuss the idea of
whether or not the intense Moon we see
in the game is actually the normal Moon
that the people of termina are used to
the reason why this is important to nail
down initially is because this will
determine whether or not the moon itself
is actually real lots of fans insinuate
that the moon really is Terminus regular
Moon complete with the eyes and teeth
and everything this is because all
things considered most of the terminium
people seem to not be concerned or
alarmed at all at the moon's appearance
and growing size as the days pass
however more and more townspokes leave
Clock Town implying that they are at
least concerned about the moon's
imminent crash course but this doesn't
prove that the Moon is a different Moon
it just proves that it was full
luckily for us there are some jugglers
that give us some insight into the
moon's appearance when talked to they
say that they are practicing for the big
carnival that only happens once in a
blue moon but then they say or in this
year's case once in a really really
scary red-eyed moon this implies that
this Moon as specifically its eyes are
abnormal the regular moonater minions
are used to which most likely looks a
lot like our own moon or even the
regular old hyrule's moon has been
either hidden or replaced entirely by
the red-eyed Moon shown in game it's
because of this that will led to the
conclusion that the in-game red-eyed
moon is actually a magical creation of
majorites Majora even possesses the moon
after ridding itself of its puppet the
Skull Kid how a link chases after the
Mars gun is transported into the moon
the interior does not make any physical
sense whatsoever though there is a field
with a tree in the middle and even
children running around the place each
wearing one of The Masks of the
corrupted Giants but Bandit what do you
think do you want to take a shot at
piecing this all together certainly now
remember as always this is just my own
Theory slash speculative thought process
and you are more than welcome to believe
whatever you would like to but I'm just
gonna come out and say it I think the
moon itself is a demon think about it
it's not Terminus normal Moon it can
fall without affecting oh I don't know
the ocean it's microscopically small
compared to anything that could actually
be considered a planetary moon it's got
eyeballs and a nose and it's got
eyeballs and a nose and teeth but
furthermore I think it is Majora like
Majora Majora I mean on a very service
level of logic you would think that the
possessed Skull Kid calling down the
duplicate moon plus this Moon having
terrifyingly glaring red eyes the likes
of which are seen on only one other
object in the entire game the Majora's
Mask itself and the fact that the mask
enters and possesses the moon would all
imply some sort of connection between
the two I think that much is rather
obvious actually personally I even think
the fact that the Majora's Mask is a
heart shape that Sprouts veiny fleshy
limbs is very telling perhaps Majora's
Mask is literally the heart of the Moon
and it's not like any of the Majora's
Mask boss forms we fight at the end of
the game are referred to as just Majora
it goes from Majora's Mask to Majora's
Incarnation to Majora's wrath leaving
the issue of just who Majora is still at
large now I already went super in depth
into the history of Majora's Mask and
how it ties into the happy mask salesman
and the little happy mask salesman
children running around in the moon in
my previous Majora's Mask boss lore
video so I won't be redundant and go
over all that again here but allow me to
summarize what we do know about the
history of the majority his mask it was
created Long Ago by an ancient tribe and
was used for hexing rituals eventually
became too problematic and the ancient
tribe decided to hide it away so what if
after countless years have passed and
the mask was finally given a body to
possess and channel its power through
the entity within the mask was able to
form a body once again in the form of
the celestial Moon and out of its anger
towards the ancient tribe that hid it
away in the shadows decides to crash
into the Earth destroying the world I
mean it even cries which combined with
its angry facial expression all but
proves the fact that the Moon is hurting
angry perhaps the story of Majora's Mask
in the skull kid in terminum the
destruction of the world is really the
story of the spirit within the mask
presumably Majora itself seeking revenge
on its captors now it is absolutely
possible that everything I just said is
complete nonsense The Mask itself does
not have to have any ties to some other
being named Majora The Mask could have
just created the moon because it wanted
to create a moon giving a little bit of
its own own likeness and having it
destroy the world because that sounded
fun I guess but hey it's Christmas you
get to choose what you'd like to believe
since none of this is confirmed anywhere
in game and if you'd like a deeper look
into the character of Majora and the
happy mask salesman be sure to check out
my Majora's Mask boss lore video but for
now that's the end of the list due to
Majora's Mask only having five well
really just four dungeons in it this one
was pretty short but I still wanted to
keep up the tradition of having a fellow
Zelda lore Creator on board in order to
help explain the Dungeons and speaking
of which huge thanks to Mr Conrad of the
Commonwealth realm for helping out with
this one now that we have done the
tropical and well scary messed up
dungeons let's do two temples that are
more in line with the season of this
upload snow ice stone and a little bit
of Christianity so head over to my
channel for the snow head and Stone
Tower temples
thank you all so much for watching if
you're still watching this please
consider leaving a like on the video to
get it spread around on YouTube and
subscribe if you haven't already to
stick around for all the juicy video
game lore diving nuggets of Joy I will
be producing in 2023 and Beyond huge
thanks as always to my Bandit crew who
make my day every single day be sure to
follow me on my socials and that's about
all I've got for this one this is Bandit
looking forward to seeing you over on
Conrad's Channel and signing out ho ho
ho
Merry Christmas
[Music]
foreign
[Music]